thank you very much everyone thank you
progress being made and I appreciate you
all joining us last night the FDA
announced groundbreaking new policies to
further increase testing over very
substantially so all states can now
authorize tests developed and used
within their borders in addition to the
FDA so the states are very much involved
they have been involved from the
beginning but we're setting it up as
much as we can and the testing
procedures are going well and within a
short period of time all of the private
labs will kick in this never been done
before and it's it's gonna be something
very I think it's gonna be incredible
if it's done properly and these are
great companies these are among the
greatest companies in the world actually
so the state's going to be dealing
through themselves and with local
government local physicians local
everybody they're also dealing with us
but we have a tremendous testing
capacity today we're also announcing a
dramatic expansion of our Medicare
telehealth services Medicare patients
can now visit any doctor by phone or
video conference at no additional cost
including with commonly used services
like FaceTime and Skype a historic
breakthrough this has not been done
before either
in addition states of the authority to
cover telehealth services for their
medical patients and by doing this the
patient is not seeing the doctor per se
but they're seeing the doctor so there's
no getting close during this time we
will not enforce applicable HIPAA
penalties so that doctors can greatly
expand care for their patients using
telehealth so the penalties won't be
enforced we encourage everyone to
maximize use of telehealth to limit
exposure to the virus it's been a very
successful method of communication but
never used on a on a scale like we're
going to use at telehealth
and you'll be able to also better
maintain hospital capacity by doing this
earlier this morning I spoke with
executives from America's fast food
industry Wendy's McDonald's all of the
the big ones Burger King and they were
great talking about the pickups in light
of yesterday's guidance you heard to
avoid eating or drinking at bars
restaurants or public food courts we
discussed the important role that the
drive-thru pickup and delivery service
can play in the weeks ahead
so that's happening and they have been
fantastic they have been absolutely
fantastic and they've been doing it
already but they're keeping it open and
smaller staffs very capable people and
very capable companies and they're doing
it pick ups our guidance yesterday urges
Americans to take action for 15 days to
help stem the outbreak so it's a 15-day
period I guess now would say it's a
14-day period 15 days from yesterday and
we're asking everyone to work at home a
possible postpone unnecessary travel and
limit social gatherings to no more than
ten people by making shared sacrifices
and temporary changes we can protect the
health of our people and we can protect
our economy because I think our economy
will come back very rapidly so it's 15
days from yesterday we'll see what
happens after that if we do this right
our country and the world frankly but
our country can be rolling again pretty
quickly pretty quickly we have to fight
that invisible enemy that I guess
unknown but we're getting to know it a
lot better today the Senate has taken up
coronavirus legislation that includes
free testing for those who need it as
well as paid sick leave and family
medical leave for work is affected by
the virus we're also committed to
getting small business a support that
they need in fact one of the things we
talked about with the fast-food
operations we spoke to the chairman and
CEOs of all of the companies but one of
the things we discussed is
actly that getting small businesses
support and flexibility that they need
for themselves and for their workers and
that's being worked on right now at my
direction secretary minuchin is meeting
today with senators on additional
stimulus packages I can tell you who is
meeting with them
late until the night last night and for
a big part of the day yesterday and
tremendous things are happening there's
great spirit tremendous spirit and I can
say that for Republicans and Democrats I
can say that with respect to Governor
Cuomo we had a great talk this morning
we're both doing a really good job and
we're coordinating it and we agree you
know different states need different
things and we we agree on that a hundred
percent but with a very good talk and I
think we're right down the same track
and it's going to be very successful New
York has a pretty big problem I guess
would be the number one hotspot that's
no fault of anybody it's just the way it
is but we're working very closely
together we're also getting FEMA very
much involved they've been involved but
now we're getting them to a different
level and we'll have everything ready
we're dealing with the Army Corps of
Engineers should that be necessary we
have them working in some cases on
standby in other cases but my
conversation with Andrew Cuomo was a
very very productive one and a very good
one I appreciate that we're giving
relief to affected industries and small
businesses and we're ensuring that we
emerge from this challenge with the
prosperous and growing economy because
that's what's going to happen it's going
to pop one day we'll be standing
possibly up here we'll say well we won
and we're going to say that sure as
you're sitting there we're gonna say
that and we're going to win and I think
well then win faster than people think I
hope later today I'll meet with the
leaders from the termined tourism
industry as well as industrial supply
retailers and wholesalers to discuss
their critical roles as you know I met
with the department store people all of
the retailers the big ones including
Walmart and others and it was great
meeting they're stocking up their stores
like they have never stopped them before
or we're trying to get people to
actually buy less if that's possible buy
less don't take everything just buy what
you need for a while it's they're gonna
stay open all hours of the day and
they've really been they've been
fantastic we're taking aggressive action
now as one nation or one family so that
America can rebound stronger frankly
stronger than ever before and we
recognize that while many American
workers can work from home many others
cannot many of our health care providers
first responders and men and women into
the food service and manufacturing are
showing that they're showing up and
standing up to provide us with the goods
and services we need so we want people
to stay home where they can but in many
cases when you talk about food service
and manufacturing certain items in
particular they are they're going in and
they're practicing all of the safety
rules and regulations that we talk about
so with that I'd like to just introduce
our great vice president Mike Pence
he'll say a few words and then I'll make
some other introductions thank you very
much Thank You mr. president good
morning it should be very clear to the
American people that President Trump has
initiated not only a whole-of-government
approach but a whole of America approach
and the president's interaction even
today and through the course of this day
with leaders in industry around the
country reflects that we're not only
bringing the full weight of the federal
government to bear but the full way of
the American economy and I know I speak
on behalf of the president when I say
how inspired we are at the way the
American people have stepped up in the
way that American businesses large and
small have stepped up this truly been
inspiring our task force met this
morning and we continue to focus on
president Trump's priorities of testing
prevention and supplies and in that
category I'm pleased to report that that
while testing is available in all 50
states as the president just indicated
through the swift action of the FDA at
the encouragement of governors around
the country now state health authorities
can authorize labs in their state and
expand
resisting testing capabilities but also
in connection with the FDA's action
which you'll hear more about in a moment
we now have continued to expand the
public and private partnership that the
president forged with vast commercial
laboratories around the country
increasing access to the high volume of
high throughput coronavirus testing that
is that is greatly expanding access even
as we speak
also our task force received a report
this morning on the progress that the US
Public Health Service and FEMA are
making working closely with state
governments and also partners in the
private sector like CVS Target Walgreens
and Walmart to expand remote testing
sites around the country and we'll have
a full report later this week as those
come online it's important the American
people understand the testing is
happening all over the country but all
of our health experts wanted me to tell
the American people you don't need the
results of testing to know what you
should do and president Trump's 15 day
coronavirus guidelines our advice for
every American in every community
they're the result of the best guidance
of CDC and our health experts and as the
president said we continue to urge every
American over the next 15 days to put
into practice the principles in the
president's coronavirus guidelines by
every American practicing these
principles we believe that we can slow
the spread of the corona virus in fact
our experts have told our Task Force
that if every American acts on the
president's coronavirus guidelines we
could see a substantial reduction in the
spread of the corona virus but as the
president said it will take all of us to
do it so if you feel sick stay home if
someone in your house tests positive
keep the entire household home
especially if you're a person with an
underlying health condition we urge you
to stay home and practice social
distancing from people though social
gatherings of more than 10 people use
drive-thru as the president discussed
with leaders in the industry to
every American especially practicing
common sense and good hygiene for the
American people as a whole the risk of
serious illness remains low but we're
asking every American to partner with us
in this effort
to slow the spread of the virus and
especially to be mindful of seniors or
others with serious underlying health
conditions for whom the threat of the
corona virus can be very significant and
very real as I said the president has
continued to push our task force to
bring a whole of government a whole of
America approach and we continue to be
inspired the way our nation's governors
and nation businesses are responding we
spoke just yesterday with the leaders of
every broadcast network in America that
will soon be unveiling a public service
campaign using CDC guidelines and
specifically as we work on the issue of
supplies meetings yesterday with
Department of Defense officials about
excess supplies the president and I will
be meeting today to speak about the
supply chain for hospitals we would make
one specific request and that is we
would urge construction companies to
donate their inventory of n95 mass to
your local hospital and forgo additional
orders of those industrial masks because
of what the president asked to be
included in legislation moving through
the Congress today those industrial
masks that they use on construction
sites are perfectly acceptable for
health care workers to be protected from
a respiratory disease but we're asking
construction companies that our
president knows very well from his
background we're asking them to donate
their n95 masks to their local hospitals
and also forego making additional orders
at the president's direction we will we
will continue to do whatever it takes
we'll continue to marshal the best of
the American people the best of all the
people behind me the people behind them
our state and local officials and we
will get through this and we will get
through this together Thank You mr.
Allen
I want to thank Chad Wolfe and homeland
security in the job they did at the
airports was really incredible they
screamed thousands and thousands of
people O'Hara got backed up but a little
bit but they got him out and but
everybody was screened and screened very
carefully they didn't want to rush it
there was 13 airports and it was it was
an incredible thing then they had a big
surge also from the UK and Ireland and
that went very smoothly but they did a
fantastic job they work long hours and
they did a fantastic job I'd like to
introduce Steve minuchin and then I'm
going to ask Steve to leave because he's
going to the hill he's been working very
hard with the Senate and with actually
with the house on a very very big bold
package it's gonna be big and it's gonna
be bold and the level again of
enthusiasm to get something done I don't
think I've ever seen anything quite like
it so Steve minuchin please Thank You
mr. president I'd like to announce some
very significant actions that the
president has approved today the first I
would say is earlier today I sent a
letter to Fed Chairman Powell approving
his request to use 13-3 and what that
will do is the Fed will be setting up a
special purpose vehicle which the
Treasury will invest 10 billion dollars
in from one of our funds that will
enable the Fed to guarantee the purchase
of a 1p one commercial paper going
forward that is a one trillion dollar
market and is critical to American
workers it's critical to American
business and it's in critical to
American savers who have a lot of that
money in money market funds so we heard
loud and clear there were liquidity
issues this is very significant and will
create I don't think we'll need to use
it all but we have the ability to have
the Fed purchase up to one trillion
dollars of commercial paper is needed
that has already created significant
stability in the market today the second
thing I would say is you know we
previously talked about
deferring IRS payments the president
earlier this morning authorized me to
announce this program I have previously
announced we would defer 200 billion the
president suggested we increased that to
300 billion which will we will be doing
now let me just be clear on the
specifics we encourage those Americans
who can file their taxes to continue to
file their taxes on April 15th because
for many Americans you will get tax
refunds and we don't want you to lose
out on those tax refunds we want you to
make sure you get them many people do
this electronically which is easy for
them and easy for the IRS if you owe a
payment to the IRS you can defer up to a
million dollars as an individual and the
reason why we're doing a million dollars
is that covers lots of pass throughs and
small businesses and ten million dollars
to corporations interest-free and
penalty free for 90 days all you have to
do is file your taxes you'll
automatically not get charged interest
in penalties now of course any American
has the right to extend their taxes
we're not taking that a right that the
president has asked us to go up to 300
billion dollars that's also an enormous
amount of liquidity in the system the
third thing is the president and I
worked on a very significant economic
stimulus plan thank you for being
available last night and throughout this
morning and I will be presenting that to
the Republicans in the Senate this
morning and also discussing that with
the house we look forward to having
bipartisan support we're now working
with the Senate to pass this legislation
very quickly and these will be payments
to small businesses we've talked about
loan guarantees to critical industries
such as Airlines and hotels and we've
also talked about a stimulus package to
the American worker you can think of
this as something like business
interruption payments for the American
workers thank you do you have any
questions for the secretary of the
Treasury
stimulus package for American workers do
you mean direct payments to Americans
are you talking about a payroll tax
holiday although the president likes the
idea that the payroll tax holiday I will
tell you what we've heard for many
people and the president has said we can
consider this the payroll tax holiday
would get people money over the next six
to eight months we're looking at sending
checks to Americans immediately and what
we've heard from hardworking Americans
many companies have now shut down
whether it's bars or restaurants
Americans need cash now and the
president wants to get cash now and I
mean now in the next two weeks I will be
previewing that with the Republicans
there's some numbers out there they may
be a little bit bigger than what's in
the process what are you going to give -
we've had discussions with all the
airline CEOs this week the airline CEOs
have had conversations with the Senate
and the house as the president said I
was up with a subset of the Republican
senators last night I've discussed that
with them I think as you know this is
worse than 9/11 for the airline industry
this is they are almost ground to a halt
the president wants to make sure that
although we don't want people to travel
unless it's critical we want to maintain
for critical travel the right to have
domestic travel not gonna comment on the
specifics I will tell you we're very
focused there's a lot of workers this is
strategically important to us and we'll
be working with Congress on the airline
industry we'll be in good shape
yeah go ahead thousand dollars tax to
every American increasing support among
Republicans and some Democrats for that
would you support that going to everyone
or would you support some sort of income
restriction on who gets a check well I
think it's clear we don't need to send
people who make a million dollars a year
checks okay but we like that's one of
the ideas we like we're gonna preview
that today and then we'll be talking
about details afterwards well I think I
think we're going to do something that
gets money to them as quickly as
possible that may not be an accurate way
of doing it because obviously some
people shouldn't be getting checks for
$1,000
we'll have a pretty good idea by the end
of the day what we're going to be doing
how was the mechanics of this work we've
been talking about a payroll tax holiday
some 500 billion dollars worth was
floated to meet sadaiva so how would
this idea of sending people to check
work would you would that be sort of an
advance on what they would pay attention
again we want to make sure Americans get
money in their pockets quickly we want
to make sure small business owners have
access to funds we want to make sure
that hotels airlines we have an entire
package will be laying out those details
later today yeah I have to say this
there are four different ways you can do
it that's a four you can hear me well
enough and magic you missed sorry okay
people help me all right those are very
important people come to think of it
especially your people look we have four
or five ways we can do it four ways in
particular I think there's a fifth
possibility but there are some very good
ways of getting the money out and
getting it out quickly payroll tax is
one way but it does come over a period
of months many months and we want to do
something much faster than that so I
think we have ways of getting money out
pretty quickly and very accurately we
have to do this now so this is now week
we are gonna work with the Senate who's
in session right now actively we will
continue to have conversations with the
house I've already spoken to Speaker
Pelosi once today this is stuff that
needs to be done now the president has
instructed me that this is no fault to
American workers for medical reasons we
are shutting down parts of this economy
and we're going to use all the tools we
have as I've said and what tools we
don't have we're going back to Congress
I got to go back to
50 billion dollars to those who might be
concerned that's - we don't want to talk
about it but it's a substantial number
we're going big the expression we could
do it two ways we could keep going back
every day or every week we're going big
and that's where Mitch McConnell that's
the way he wants to go that's the way I
want to go I think we want to get it
done and have a big infusion as opposed
to going through little meetings every
every couple of days we don't want to do
it that way we want to go big go solid
the country is very strong we've never
been so strong and that's what we're
going to be doing we don't want with
this invisible enemy we don't want
Airlines going out of business we don't
want people losing their jobs or not
having money to live when they were
doing very well just four weeks ago so
we're going big and that's the way it'll
be and that's the way everybody seems to
like it on the hill any other questions
restaurants today was any type of
emergency assistance discussed on that
call a lot of restaurants have to close
even if they are doing delivery they're
not making as much money as they would
with a full house let me make two
comments on on the restaurants and the
president understands this this was
emphasized this morning first of all we
want to make sure that the states allow
the drive-thru portion of these fast
foods to stay open particularly in a
time period where we're telling people
don't go to restaurants these companies
feed a big part of America and I expect
they're gonna feed a bigger part of
America the second thing they asked me
to emphasize I wasn't going to do it now
but as long as you asked many of these
companies have apps you can order ahead
of time that way when you get there it's
as simple as they'll have it packed they
can give it to you as social distancing
and it'll be very fast so we expect that
they will be able to feed a large part
of the population and in regards to
support I will say a lot of these
businesses are small businesses or
companies franchisees 500 or less and we
have a specific program we'll be
unveiling that helps all businesses
small and medium-sized businesses of 500
and lessens
regarding of mariya corporation and
announced that it is furloughing
thousands of individuals because of the
impacts of the coronavirus rule your
legislation helped those individuals I
hope so that's one of the reasons why we
got to act very quickly because we
understand whether it's the airlines
hotels for good reasons to protect the
United States on medical issues these
businesses are shut down and the
president wants to make sure as I've
said we will use all the powers we have
you saw this today trillion dollars of
potential liquidity into the market and
the powers we don't have we're going to
Congress and I will say there's a lot of
bipartisan support for these issues so
I'm going to apologize because I have to
go deal with some other I do want to
comment on this okay we absolutely
believe in keeping the markets open okay
Americans need to know they have access
to their money after September 11th the
only reason why the markets were closed
was because the technology was disrupted
I've been on the phone with the major
banks with the New York Stock Exchange
everybody wants to keep it open we may
get to a point where we shorten the
hours if that's something they need to
do but Americans should know that we are
going to do everything to make sure that
they have access to their money at their
banks to the money in their 401ks and to
the money in stocks so I want to just be
very clear we intend to keep the markets
open and the banks are record-setting
strong so we have we have that which is
a much different event than what we had
not so long ago
mr. president you mentioned the Army
Corps of Engineers of the fennec
conversation with Governor Cuomo people
leaves in New York is going to run out
of hospital beds are you prepared to
mobilize we weren't asked to increase
capacity that's what's starting to we're
starting the process and it's a process
we hope it's not going to be necessary
but it could be necessary the state is
working on it very hard themselves but
we'll probably supplement what they're
doing and you've been given that many of
the precursors for our pharmaceuticals
come from China and there have been
destroyed as there have been supply
disruption that supply chain has been
broken to some degree do you expect that
we could run into a shortage of
prescription drugs no I don't see that
at all and I think jen has every
incentive to make sure that things work
well Jonah wants to make sure that
things work very well they have every
incentive to do so Jeff the governor of
Ohio has called off the election that
was supposed to happen today the primary
election do you agree with that decision
and what steps are you taking to ensure
that elections going forward if this
pandemic I continues that elections will
be able to happen including the course
to think one of the fall well the
governor I was doing a great job he
called it off and we'll see what happens
as a court case and it hasn't been fully
determined yet but if he called it off I
could understand that because you know
he he's definitely somebody that knows
what he's doing
we'll be seeing what very soon you know
they're going by the rule of 10 as
opposed to 50 and it's pretty tough I
would say probably you could violate
that if you wanted to for an election I
just think an election is a very special
thing he's going to chose he chose a
different date I think a date sometime
in June but that would be a decision
that would be made by him he felt it was
necessary the courts are somebody's
challenging it so the courts will
ultimately decide what are you doing to
ensure that further elections if we're
still in this situation of
from now two months we all know what I'm
doing Jones very simple we're getting
rid of this virus that's what we're
doing that's the best thing we can do by
the way for the markets for everything
is very simple very simple solution we
want to get rid of it we want to have
very as few deaths as possible this is a
horrible thing you look at what's going
on with Italy we don't want to be in a
position like that but a much larger
because we're a much larger country we
don't want to be there and I think we've
done really well I think we've done well
I think the states have done well we're
all working together the best thing we
can do is get rid of the virus once it's
gone it's gonna pop back like nobody's
ever seen before that's my opinion but I
think it will pop back like nobody has
ever seen before please facilities the
Army Corps of Engineers build and also
what specific measures are you taking to
try to increase the number of
ventilators in the fight we've ordered
massive numbers of ventilators we have
by any normal standards we have a lot of
respirators ventilators we have
tremendous amounts of equipment but
compared to what we're talking about
here this has never been done before and
yesterday I gave the governor's the
right to go order directly if they want
if they feel they can do it faster then
going through the federal government now
we've knocked out all of the bureaucracy
it's very direct but it's still always
faster to order directly and I gave them
that was totally misinterpreted by the
New York Times on purpose unfortunately
but the the but it's very important yes
please a president directed us to work
with the Department of Defense there's
two ways that DoD can be helpful in
terms of expanding medical capacity I
know the governor of New York has asked
us to look at the Army Corps of engineer
which could perhaps renovate existing
buildings but the president also has us
inventory especially yesterday in
Washington State we have resources in
that part of the country that we could
move and as governors make these
requests we will process them bring them
to the president but there are two
different lanes that VOD can provide in
addition to many men
Oh supplies to augment our national
reserves and the president has tasked us
to to evaluate and make available and to
consider every every request from
governor's for either field hospitals
expanding facilities or the Army Corps
of engineer that could retrofit existing
buildings
the Army Corps is very prepared to do as
we say and we're looking at where it's
going but and they do call them mash
hospitals but the field hospitals go
very quickly there we have them we have
all of this equipment in stock and we're
looking at different sites and a few
different locations and we're not going
to need them and West Virginia where so
far I guess they have none still none
still none West Virginia Big Jim the
governor's you must be doing a good job
that's what's reported reporting issue
or is that that they have no cases well
that's all that I just see West Virginia
is the only one that has no cases so
obviously that's being treated
differently than in New York or or
California
different parts of California I do say
this so the the Army Corps of Engineers
is ready willing and able we have to
give them the go-ahead if we find that
it's going to be necessary we think we
can have quite a few units up very
rapidly I'm going to work with Governor
Cuomo I'm going to work with a number of
the governor's governor Newsom has been
very generous and his in his words and
I'm being generous to him too because
we're all working together very well and
and I think a lot a lot of very positive
things have taken place we're talking to
California about different sites but we
can we can have a lot of units up fairly
quickly if we think we need them I think
what I'll do is I might ask Seema to say
a few words on the telehealth and then
we can get back to this place Sheila
Thank You mr. president
and as the president announced earlier
we are doing a dramatic expansion of
what's known as telehealth for our 62
million Medicare beneficiaries who are
amongst the most vulnerable to the
corona virus
and we're acting in accord with the
appropriations bill that was signed on
March 6 as well as the president's
emergency declaration last week and this
action is a part of our broader effort
to ensure that government requirements
rules and regulations don't get in the
way of patient care during an emergency
and today's announcement builds on the
significant progress of the president
has already made over the past three
years around telehealth services and
while we have allowed for virtual
check-ins
full telehealth benefits have been
restricted to those living in rural
areas established patients and just for
those brief visits but no longer
Medicare beneficiaries across the nation
no matter where they live will now be
able to receive a wide range of services
via telehealth without ever having to
leave home and these services can also
be provided in a variety of settings
including nursing homes hospital
outpatient departments and more and
thanks to the leadership of HHS will
also be temporarily relaxing certain
HIPPA requirements so that doctors can
provide telehealth with their own phones
and we'll be using enforcement
discretion when it comes to collecting
co-pays so that cost won't be a barrier
this is a part of our larger efforts
around mitigation and as we are
encouraging Americans to stay home
whenever possible we don't want our
Medicare policies getting in the way and
so consider the implications of this
perhaps an elderly patient with diabetes
needs routine checkup and this has
nothing to do with the corona virus and
so with our new telehealth benefits this
person who's not really who's at risk
for the corona virus doesn't have to
venture outside their home they can talk
to their doctor via Skype and they don't
have to risk exposure to the virus and
they can receive that care from the
safety of their own home it could be
another Medicare recipient who's
experiencing mild flu-like symptoms and
instead of leaving the house and sitting
in a waiting room full of other
vulnerable people they can also receive
advice from their doctor from their home
and this shift is very important for
clinicians and providers who over the
coming weeks will face considerable
strain on their time and resources and
now Medicare patients who don't absolute
we need to come in to an office won't
have to and this allows the healthcare
system to prioritize for care for those
that are more that have more needs or in
dire need and preserves protective
equipment as well state Medicaid
agencies can also provide telehealth
services without federal approval and so
we're asking all states to make this
available as well and we've also asked
private insurance companies to expand
their telehealth benefits and make it
clear to their providers and their
members what they cover as our nation
seeks to balance the twin imperatives of
getting Americans the care that they
need during this outbreak and limiting
the spread of the virus the impact of
this historic action simply cannot be
overstated
in an emergency those on the front line
shouldn't have to worry about federal
rules and red tape hamstringing them
when they need flexibility above all
else and we're doing everything in our
power to make sure that that doesn't
happen I also just want to briefly
mention that because of the president's
emergency declaration we do have the
ability to provide a lot of Medicaid
waivers and Florida was the first state
to be approved we were able to do that
in a matter of days thank you any
questions where do you see your citizens
go for instructions on how to do the
tillow they should call their doctor's
office and their doctor's office can
tell them how to do that I'm also you
know there may be some of our Medicare
members that may not have access to
equipment so we're asking family members
but to help with this but also
respecting the requirements around
social distancing and if any of those
family members or neighbors have
symptoms they should obviously stay
won't be posting members or so that's
correct
I used where to do it if you post and
they can also call our 1-800 Medicare
number and they can also get information
those phone lines are open
Thank You ed well if you say if we worry
about where we're going
dr. Burks how the system is working well
thank you very much
as we talked about earlier this week the
commercial system is rapidly advancing
in the testing capabilities as of today
our public health laboratories meaning
the CDC and the public health labs have
reported out 30 1878 tests so almost
32,000 tests the clinical laboratories
the association of clinical laboratories
have reported out 20 about 27,000 tests
and most importantly of those 27,000
during the cumulative period of time
8200 of them were yesterday
this is showing the dramatic ramp is the
high throughput comes in we don't have
the numbers this morning from the
American Hospital Association which
means all the individual Hospital
laboratories we will have that up coming
in the next day or so and then
ambassador birx will have this whole
process a fixed under with the
legislation that everything will roll up
into a common reporting probably by the
end of next week in terms of our drive
through laboratories again these are
blossoming all over the country by
individual states the ones that we are
heavily involved in and really pushing
equipment to we expect over the next few
days to begin setting up 47 of these in
approximately 12 states the material is
already palletized and being shipped to
the locations most cities have the
specific locations some do not but it's
still going to a central receiving and
we know that we'll be deploying at least
140 commissioned Corps officers about
half of the sites have reported their
requirements about 140 officers will be
going we expect that to go up so this is
going on the way we expected we did a
trial site yesterday with a full mobile
unit for driving through with full PPE
we had a lot of kinks in the system as
you can expect that's why we do a test
before we go out into the field don't
expect these to be a hundred percent
perfect the moment they come they're
going to be adapted to the state in the
local situation but we're very confident
these will add testing to the already
very robust health care system and
commercial system Thank You mr.
president
and this has never been done before and
it sets a great roadmap for future
should we have something like this in
the future I hope we don't but it's
never been done before and they've done
an incredible job and again we're
working with the states and relying on
the states we have to because they they
have its point of sale it's point of
sight and we're in I think just about
every instance getting along really well
with the with the states if I could dr.
Burks if you could say a couple of words
please so I think what you've been
hearing from us is to find solutions
that are high-quality and sustainable
based on the front line workers and
governor's request and I those come in
on the governor's call we've been
immediately responsive to those and
that's the the level of red tape and
bureaucracy that we have removed I think
that point about sustainability and
quality is very important because as the
president says we're creating a roadmap
for a different level of functionality
for future pandemics our flu pandemic
preparedness plan was a plan now we're
seeing where we have to revise where we
have to create new avenues of research
and new avenues of work to really ensure
that the need of the American people can
be reached
we were adamant about having a high
quality test based on our commercial
vendors over the next few months you
will begin to see that other tests that
were utilized around the world we're not
of the same quality resulting in false
positives and potentially false
negatives these tests were studied and
studied by the FDA to really ensure that
they are that level of quality and we've
given the states the permission to
ensure that same level of quality now I
wanted to say one minute on the testing
testing should not be used as an
assessment of your risk we are asking
every single American no matter what
your generation from Z and up to X and
Millennials in between to really ensure
that you're following these guys
we hear every night of people who are
not in work moving that time into bars
and other areas of large gatherings if
we continue with that process we will
fail in containing this virus so every
single generation has a role to play
we're asking our older generation to
stay in their homes and we're asking the
younger generations to support them in
social contacting through videos and
other Skype type functions or just the
simple telephone we're asking the
younger generations to stop going out in
public places to bars and restaurants
and spreading a symptomatic virus onto
countertops and knobs and grocery stores
and grocery carts I heard an innovation
last night and this morning again on the
news I really want to applaud the
private sector who are now creating
senior only shopping times I think
that's extraordinary I think that shows
what America brings and I think other
countries will learn from us about how
to really protect seniors in this type
of way I'm hoping that carries through
to next year when we have our flu
epidemic where we can really have a very
different prototype for a file of the
amount of mortality that we have during
flu that we never talked about anywhere
from 15,000 to 45,000 individuals are
lost every year if we learn how to do
this well and sustain some of those core
changes we can change the way
respiratory viruses not only for this
but the future affect Americans it's a
big thing
a question on the clinical data so we've
had now only 5000 people test positive
we've had 90 deaths or so when are we
going to know the data of who those
people are who has been infected what
the ages are what the pre-existing
conditions are how serious it was both
for those who have been tested positive
but also those who have died well you
are singing my sheet of music I'm very
data oriented so thank you for bringing
up this issue of data I really want to
applaud HHS we had a discussion about
this several days ago they've made calls
in to Seattle and California to really
understand that and also importantly to
understand how many of their patients
needed ventilators how many of them
needed oxygen support how many of them
needed and what they needed could we
predict early someone who was going to
have a more difficult course these are
all the questions we're asking right and
answering right now we did get an early
report back from Santa Clara and Seattle
we're digesting it we just got it this
morning we're looking at that carefully
because we think that roadmap is very
important to other communities we have
not discussed this with New York yet we
do know from other countries and that
all is available online that profile you
can see that mortality under 30 is
extraordinarily low the mortality across
the board outside of Wuhan is now
settling somewhere around 0.7 but that
should not be reassuring because it's
much higher in people with pre-existing
medical conditions even if young and
people that are older with pre-existing
medical conditions and so we still want
every American focused on doing what
they can do today to change the course
of this pandemic commit to making that
data public so we will all know we're
committed not only to making it public
but to have a website that everyone can
see in real-time
there you are signaling a much more
aggressive posture toward containment
mitigation now in many states have been
very aggressive but there is a small
number of states that has not have not
issued public guidance to their
residents is it important for the
success of the effort that 100% of the
states be forward leaning on this and if
so mr. president what would be your
message to those states that have not
okay so that's why the vice president
and the president yesterday issued those
critical guidelines as I said just
morning on Fox and Friends you can look
at them as with guidelines you can look
at requirements and you can look at him
as the president asking every American
in every state to follow those that's
why we put them out at the federal level
we wanted to make sure every American
knew what they could do today to change
the course of this epidemic
I think it's empowering I think it says
all of us have a social responsibility
to each other and that's why we believe
that every mayor and every governor
should be instituting these guidelines
that came from the White House and the
President of the United States and we've
been very tough for those states I know
exactly who you're talking to it we've
been very tough in it thank you testing
you've been telling us for days now that
millions of tests have been sent out so
why have fewer than 60,000 people
actually been tested I think you will
see different numbers this week you
heard just at 8,000 remember all of
these tests the high speed tests were
approved last Friday last Friday night
and last Thursday night I think if I
could talk to thermo Fisher and the
other groups that have these platforms
out there do not rely on a pull
technology push out those tests because
we can only make them available groups
have to order them so I we've been
talking to thermo Fisher one of the key
platforms to push out tests based on
need and not wait for orders
she was getting the test out or is it
getting the test conducted we that's a
great question I know part of it is
getting the test out right now I think
the Admiral and others are working on
getting that the issues related to
getting the tests conducted obviously
that does take time he is working on
innovative solutions that are creative
and sustainable that will be a
game-changer in testing but we don't
have the data yet this is a critical
comparator can you do it yourself can
you actually sample yourself these these
are the kinds of things we're working on
right now and he's getting the data for
us the governors and the states are
doing a lot of it with even our tests
thank you
can you give us a sense of how long
these tough new restrictions will need
to be in place until we start to see the
rate of this virus going down and also
can you speak to this study that as many
as 2.2 million people in the United
States could die if there weren't this
type of action by the government taken I
think you know models are models and
they're based on input and they're based
on infectiousness without any controls I
can tell you we've never seen that level
of infections that models up to that 2.2
million and mortality so we are looking
at that we are having a particularly
model meeting tomorrow I think that's
really going to be important I've dealt
with a lot of modelers in my time
they're wonderful people
but they all have their favorite inputs
and they all have their favorite
integration functions so we're
evaluating all of those so we can
integrate and create the best model for
the United States based on the best data
and that first set of recommendations
you saw were based on what we could do
today to prevent anything that looks
like that if I could just say one other
thing to the hospitals and dentists out
there things that don't need to be done
over the next two weeks don't get it
done if you're a person with an electric
cert elective surgery you don't want to
go into a hospital right now there's a
lot of distraction there's a lot of
people doing a lot of other things to
save people's lives
let's all be responsible and cancel
things that we can cancel to really free
up hospital beds in space and then let's
do everything that we can to ensure that
we don't need the ventilators because
we've protected the people who would
have needed to use them and are you
looking at the possibility of more
actions like for example limiting travel
within the United States or you look
it's possible it's possible we'll see
how it goes there's been great
cooperation with local governments
States we'll see how it goes it's going
it's going right now pretty well yeah
[Music]
the defense production act to get more
of those medical supplies differently
well we're able to do that if we have to
right now we haven't had to but it's
certainly ready if I want it we can do
it very quickly we've studied it very
closely over two weeks ago actually
we'll make that decision pretty quickly
if we need it we hope we don't need it
it's a big step for help because you
know when you say the stage in
particular three states need some help
and some states you know have two people
three people no people in the case of
again West Virginia so we're looking at
it very closely we've taken it apart
fifteen different ways it's a very
difficult thing to do it's a very big
step and if we need that step we'll take
it okay first question a lot of people
have got travel to places that are
considered hot spots you know Caribbean
Mexico that sort of thing over the next
few weeks would you recommend that they
follow through these plans I would just
say enjoy your home stay I would just
say right now we we have to get this
problem fixed and then we'll get back
into business real really quick we'll
open up our country we'll open up our
society the world will hopefully open up
we see areas of the world that are that
haven't done well and we see areas that
are doing very well and I would put us
in the category of doing very well for a
country so big I think that I would
recommend that they just enjoy their
living room
[Music]
what do you say to people who are not
heating these guidelines from the White
House and then also have a question on
asymptomatic yeah doctor problems I'm
not happy with those people if they're
not but you know those people are being
shouted down by other people they know
they're being it's almost like self
policing people went in there are a
couple of instances I guess probably
more than a couple where people are not
happy when they see others doing what
they're not supposed to be done and we
have to get rid of this we have to win
this war and ideally quickly quickly
there's the longer it takes it's not a
good situation and I'm not even talking
about the economy I'm talking about
the lives of a lot of people yeah please
yeah I think it's all the work in
progress what President Trump has made
clear to industries around the country
is that we're gonna do whatever it takes
we understand this is an extraordinary
moment in the life of our nation it's
the reason why the president brought in
leaders of the financial sector airline
industry he'll meet with all no
additional industry leaders today in
tourism and hospitality but he has
tasked the secretary of the Treasury to
work with members of Congress in both
parties to make sure that we construct
the kind of economic support that will
allow those industries to weather the
period of the coronavirus and then to
come back stronger than ever before
we've had we've had such incredible I
don't know it's almost the worst spirit
is the best way it's like a spirit the
banks have come in and the banks are
doing things that they would have never
done they're working on extensions and
lots of things that they wouldn't have
done co-pays with regard to the
insurance companies I mean for them to
be doing what they're doing you know all
about the co-pays they would have never
done that and they did
they were in my office they I would say
the 11 biggest in this country I guess
probably the 11 biggest of the world the
big ones all the big ones and they they
did things on copay that nobody would be
doing that they wouldn't have done in a
million years but they're doing it
there's a great spirit going on right
now in the country so you want to yes
please doctor pouchy doctor pouchy you
said you like being accused of
overreacting because that is an
indication we may be doing things
necessary to beat this bend the curve
how long do you think it will take for
you to be confident that yes we're
bending the curve or no or not you know
I can't give you a firm number on that
because the dynamics of outbreaks in
some respects are predictable
historically they do this and that we
don't know because this is really
unprecedented I mean of all the
outbreaks that I've been involved with
over the last at least 36 years and then
going historically back we've never had
a situation where the mobilization of
all the different components travel
restrictions internal the containment
mitigation financial assistance public
health assistant testing so we don't
really know but the one thing I do know
I do know that if you look at models
with all of their Vice Institutes of
models is that when you have input into
the kinds of mitigations and things that
we're doing we're gonna see a hump
instead of a peak I would be really
surprised if all the things that we're
doing and and this is really a a
comprehensive approach I was struck as I
was listening to everyone make their
their presentations that you know I'm a
scientist I'm a health person and I'm a
physician who sees patients so I look at
it from one particular standpoint but
what I'm being impressed by is that this
is really a comprehensive thing that has
multiple components different all of
them got to succeed if we're gonna get
to that endpoint that I've described
multiple times from this podium so I
hope that if everyone does their job
we're gonna be able to give you a number
and say you know
we've seen that inflection and we're
coming down I would hesitate to do it
now to be honest with you because it
might be misleading and I don't want to
be misleading I just want to say one
other thing because I heard dr. Burks
say it and I think we need to say it
over and over again when I was young a
long time ago I felt that I was
invulnerable the way I think many of us
feel were invulnerable and when we're
asking the young people to help us with
this mitigation strategy by staying out
of the bars staying out of the
restaurants really trying to distance
yourself don't get the attitude well I'm
young I'm invulnerable you are well in
some respects you're certainly less
vulnerable than I am however what you
might inadvertently do and I know you
don't want to do that you don't want to
put your loved ones at risk particularly
the ones who are elderly and the ones
who have compromised conditions we can't
do this without the young people
cooperating please cooperate with us
thank you
[Music]
but there is currently a new study out
of China found that the vast majority of
cases 86% weren't untested patients with
mild - no symptoms so what does that say
about the impact of testing and does it
mean that testing should actually go
beyond the sickest patients you know
that question keeps coming up and I'm
not gonna evade the question but I want
to make a point we tend to think that
we're not gonna be able to mitigate or
contain without testing they complement
each other in some respects but they're
separate channels even if we had no
testing we should be doing what we're
doing now the question are asking so I
won't evade it is specifically would it
be important outside of a doctor patient
coming in together of knowing what's out
there what might be under the radar
screen the answer to your question is
yes so let me tell you what the CDC is
doing right now they're going out there
and part of their program is to get a
feel for what is there that wasn't
initially thought to be corona virus
that was thought to be something else
when you do that you're also going to
get a feel of what the penetrance is in
society so we are heading with the high
throughput things that you've been
hearing about to get an answer to your
question you know it's possible I mean I
I know the governor has been really I
believe doing a really good job of
trying to stay ahead of this 45 days is
not unreasonable you have to be careful
when you get a number you own the number
and then if the number doesn't come out
you're in trouble and that's the reason
why from our standpoint from the federal
government we're talking about a range
so within that range I mean it isn't
like you want to be correct for the sake
of being correct but you don't want to
be Wed to something and then have to
back off
what is it when is the soonest that will
know that these new guidelines are
actually bending the curve or actually
working and is there a point in time
where you you know in the next couple of
weeks where you'll be able to tell the
president more draconian measures are
needed well okay so what's happening I
mean if you look as a metaphor it's kind
of like a race against a virus if left
to its own devices will do this and us
trying to somehow blunt that now you
could see the virus going up and up and
your effect your work what you're trying
to do may actually be having an effect
but you may not see it because it'll
still be going up and as you're trying
to implement your your interference with
the virus you may not realize that you
actually interfering and I'll say wait a
minute it's still going up what's going
on you've done nothing but you don't
know whether it would do this versus
that so the answer to your question it
probably would be several weeks and
maybe longer
before we know whether we're having an
effect it may be at the end of the day
we'll see a curve that would have been
way way up but I wouldn't like put us to
task every few days well wait a minute
it's going up is it working or not that
would be really misleading if we do that
recommendation against and today the
governor of Alabama issued her own
guidelines it was
against gatherings of 25 or more people
what is your recommendation for people
of Alabama people across all of the
country as far as the guidelines that
were announced yesterday by the federal
okay so one thing we don't want to do is
to get hung up on the difference between
ten and twenty five I think you might
agree with that when we give guidelines
they're only guidelines we sit down we
look at the data as dr. Berg said we're
data-driven and we say on different
models ten looks good if someone wants
to do 25 we're not gonna fault them but
if someone wants to come to us and ask
us what we think the best is we stand by
the numbers it isn't perfect it isn't
precise math it's assumptions and it's
data that make you get your decision in
every city in the country was playing by
the same yes of course but this is the
United States of America there's a lot
of free enterprise there people do their
own thing and quite frankly I don't
think there's a big deal difference
between ten and twenty five we got many
many more important things to worry
about than that difference supply chains
and then talking about preparedness for
the future yesterday Larry Kudlow said
that there was an idea of floating
around the administration to cut taxes
for companies who would be bringing
their supply chickens back to United
States he said he specifically liked
immediate hundred percent right Oscar
you know structures equipment but he
said you hadn't endorsed that yet would
you endorse not yelling they're gonna
have many ideas that's one of them
frankly and we're looking at creating
incentives for companies not only that
type of company but other companies
we're also looking to help companies
such as the airline industry within the
airline industry and we'll be doing that
we will be doing that this is not their
fault and they've been very
understanding actually and we're gonna
be helping them we will have a very
powerful airline industry and it'll
start up as soon as this is over we'll
we'll have those we'll have those planes
ready to go so we have to help them
during the short term we're very
important yeah please
their president I wanted to know have
you taken a look at some of these models
such as the Imperial College London
model that kind of poses a very
difficult choice whether it's shutting
down society or overwhelming the
healthcare Gladstone
is that something that we look at every
model we've relied on the very talented
people and there's no better team that
the people be behind me and I will say
that all of the people that have done
those models are all in constant touch
with dr. Burks and Tony and everybody
that you've been hearing so much from
over the last couple of weeks we've
looked at we've looked at many different
models and the model we have is we want
to save a lot of lives we want to save a
lot of lives if we get too steep in that
curve you're gonna lose a lot of lives
perhaps unnecessarily now we're going to
find out if everything has a risk we're
going to see but if people do what we're
telling them to do what we're asking
them to do you're gonna see the saving
of a lot of lives now Boris in UK
yesterday you so what happened it looked
like they were going a different way but
that he went away of similar I guess
simpler I don't know exactly but I would
say we had a conversation yesterday
similar to what we're doing so a lot of
people seem to think this is going to be
we are we are looking to save the
maximum number of lives everything else
is going to come back a life is never
going to come back but everything else
our economy is gonna come roaring back
you're gonna know we're gonna know we're
gonna all know that day if nobody was
asking about the day when will you know
when will you know we're gonna know all
of a sudden we're gonna say wow that's
looking good that's looking good that's
looking good and we're going to be on
the other side of the curve and that's a
day that we look forward to
at the time to implement these much more
stringent social distancing measures no
I don't think so this is where we were
going I really think from the beginning
this is where we were going this is what
we had in mind
we were just we're just going step by
step that was the next step the next
logical step
as dr. foutch she said and I think very
importantly one of the most important
things when you write the history of
this was the fact that we closed it down
to China and Europe but in particular
China we closed it down to China the
source very very early very very early
far earlier than even the great
professionals wanted to do and I think
in the end that's going to be but that
will have saved a tremendous no some
people did note that your tone seems
more somber yesterday you talked about
that August timeline did you see a
projection some people thought perhaps
that two million potentially that could
die maybe prompted part of that was
there a shift in tone I didn't think I
mean I have seen that where people
actually liked it but I didn't feel
different I've always known this is a
this is a real this is a pandemic I felt
it was a pandemic long before it was
called a pandemic all you had to do is
look at other countries I think now it's
in almost a hundred and twenty countries
all over the world no I've always viewed
it as very series there was no
difference yesterday from days before I
feel the tone is similar but some people
said it wasn't
genomic advisor said almost 100% chance
of a recession do you see it that way
it could be I mean I don't think in
terms of recession I think in terms of
getting it out because when we're
finished with the virus we will win we
will win and when that victory takes
place our economy is going to go through
the roof it is so pent up it is so built
up it is so ready to go in an upward
direction but we have to knock out this
enemy this is a really tough enemy but
we have to knock out all of us that's
all of us so I don't think in terms of
recession not recession it's words we
have to knock out this and we will have
an economy I actually think we'll have
an economy like we've never had before
it's all pent up I think the question
about about the actions that the
president authorized beginning in
January when he took the unprecedented
step of suspending all travel from China
have the efforts to issue travel
advisories for portions of Italy and
South Korea and then to begin screening
all the passengers the efforts regarding
suspending travel for Europe and what
went into effect at midnight last night
adding the UK and Ireland that have all
been informed by the experts that are
surrounding us
what the president's asked us to do from
the very beginning as dr. Burks and dr.
fountian say is let's follow the data
bring the president the best options in
response to what is actually happening
on the ground but but with regard to
yesterday's a 15 day slow the spread
plan our team unanimously brought to the
president these very strong
recommendations for every American
because we truly believe we are at a
point in this epidemic in our country
when we can reduce the number of people
that actually are exposed to or contract
the coronavirus but will continue to
bring the best data the best evidence
and the best recommendations frankly of
the best health experts in the world and
the president will continue to make
decisions that put the health of America
first
in other words reduce the number of
people that die that's what we're trying
to do and when you
the steep curve a lot of people are
gonna die a lot of people you know the
worst ever they say 1918 and I don't
have to go into the numbers but there
were unbelievable numbers had they known
and had they done what we had now it
would have been a very much different
story it would still be tragic but it
would have been a very much different
but that was that was the one that
people write about that was an
incredible that was an incredible
pandemic like we haven't seen but we
have we have done something that I hope
hopefully we will all have made the
right moves we're all of this together
including you and we want to see fair
press and and I tell you what it's been
generally speaking I think it's been
it's been a great thing to see it's been
very very the the getting along with
Democrats getting along with Republicans
for the Democrats themselves there's
been a lot of spirit there's been a lot
of things happening that I haven't seen
happen in the first almost now three and
a half years it's been very nice to see
that's one of the good things but what
really the good thing is we have to
knock it out we have to win and we want
to keep that slope as low as possible
because that's a lot of lives in there
mr. president this is not a huge impact
on China's economy as well have you
believed any indication from officials
there that they're going to have trouble
meeting the purchase agreements part of
the phase one deal particularly the
agricultural buy well they need our
product very badly and no I haven't
received any way good relationship with
China I have not received anything to
that no we have a signed agreement
they're going to be buying and they have
been buying a lot of product yeah please
earlier today doctor burse was talking
about the possibility of our hospital
system
bird over text and she talked about in
certain options that are available to
the United States here that happens
including VA hospitals right a
Department of Defense medical treatment
facilities and even hospital ships at
what point do you tap in to those
options well I'll know the point and by
speaking with Governor Cuomo and other
governor's we're gonna know the points
it's gotta be different for New York
that it's gonna be from you know Iowa or
from Idaho or from West Virginia frankly
or for you know it's it's different New
York he's got a big problem the state of
Washington is a big problem California
has some big problems everyone's doing a
good job but we're gonna know what it
will be and I believe it'll be more spot
that it will be it's not gonna be the
whole thing it's going to be spots there
are some hot spots that are in trouble
big trouble
and there are other areas that are in no
trouble at all they watch it on
television they don't know you know it's
just not affecting them and that's
they're lucky they're lucky but there
are areas of the country that don't have
much of a problem and some that don't
have any problem they're not gonna have
a problem with hospitals but some areas
like New York California state of
Washington they're going to have some
difficulty and when we see that coming
we're going to be in there were already
making preparation for it
Senator Marco Rubio of Florida your
trade adviser Peter Navarro have been
recommending an executive order that
would ensure that the raw materials for
pharmaceuticals and medical devices are
manufactured here in the United States
we were getting some indications last
week that you were close to signing this
executive order can you tell us well
we're looking at different things John I
don't want to say exactly right now
China has been sending us everything we
need but we're we're looking at some
alternatives yes we are looking for
alternatives and we have other places
Ireland does a lot of work for us you
know that in that world in the pharma
world a very tremendous producer and we
are looking to bring a lot more back
home excuse me you know me for a long
time I've been talking about this for
many years long before I decided to run
for president I've been talking about
this and we have to be able to take care
of our country and
that was one of the many things on the
list so we'll be talking about it but we
are we are discussing it in Marcos very
much involved and Peter is very much and
a lot of people are involved and a lot
of people feel that way but we'll be
discussing as opposed it's non citizens
are you considering not to the United
States United States of course
are you considering closing the land
borders in the United States and also
you disel Canada has not closed it to
the United States so we're working very
closely with Canada and but they have
not closed it they have closed it to the
world but they have not closed it to the
United States in the u.s. land border I
don't want to say that but we are
discussing things with Canada and we're
discussing things with Mexico quite
honestly and again the relationship is
outstanding with both outstanding we
just signed our deal u.s. MCA and the
relationship is very strong criticized
you for using the phrase Chinese virus
how do you feel about that you gave to
continue using that phrase well China
was putting out information which was
false that our military gave this to
them that was false and rather than
having an argument I said I have to call
it where it came from it did come from
China so I think it's a very accurate
term but no I didn't appreciate the fact
that China was saying that our military
gave it to them our military did not
give give it to anybody using that
phrase crazy stigma no I don't think so
no I think saying that our military gave
it to them creates a stigma please
travel and tourism executive
today what specific help are you going
to offer to them or is it still free
well we're gonna help they need help
look let's face it you know they go from
having record-breaking years this is the
third year of record-breaking year's
travel and tourism airlines everything
they were doing record numbers ordering
new planes building new hotels
everything was really hunky-dory and
then one day we hear about this rumour
in China and we find out it's much more
than a rumor and then all of a sudden we
make a great decision to close it up
early it would be a whole different
world we a whole different world but we
make a decision to close it up to China
and all of a sudden tourism and and then
we close it up to Europe which you know
people never heard of this before I'm
not sure that that's ever been done I
know that when I made the decision to
close it to China people told me that's
never been done before but it was a
great decision we make good decisions so
I'll tell you my best decision the
people behind me are total pros all over
the world they're respected dr. Burks
Anthony who's become wizard to become a
major television star for all the right
reasons now he's just so professional so
good the people that we have working
here had been incredible and they're
totally respected the Admiral has been
incredible having to do with the testing
incredible and he's viewing this as
testing also for the future we're
building a platform when we took over
this platform first thing the Admiral
said was this wasn't that designed for
what we're talking about millions of
people it wasn't and it's nobody's fault
it's not like who could have ever
predicted anything like this but we
broke it down and it's really gonna be
an incredible system and it is now a
great system I just I just want to say
these are incredible people standing
behind me they're the most respected in
the world every country that you've
mentioned today so far has called them
and they call them all the time for
advice there's nobody better than what
we have
why didn't we seem dr. Redfield the last
couple days running to see Joe he's
doing a good job we're very happy with
him mr. president yesterday we were
being told that the payroll tax was
gonna comprise the lion's share of
fiscal stimulus right we also had the
markets fall quite dramatically
yesterday and we did that it's important
is it about the federal tax did that
inform your decision what in what in
what made you make that change and when
did you make that well I didn't make a
change we'll look at the payroll tax and
we're looking at various other forms of
getting money to people and the payroll
tax is something that I've always liked
problem is it does take a period of time
you know months before they really see
something and we don't really have
months in terms of people living you
know a lot of these you have you have
people that work on tips you have people
in our it's a large number of people
it's a tremendous who would think this
right but and they do nicely they work
very hard but they work on tips we have
to take care of our people we don't want
to have people suffering during this
period it wasn't their fault that the
this thing all of a sudden was upon us
so we're looking at various we're also
looking at payroll tax you know it's
possible it's also possible we'll do a
percentage of payroll tax and then other
things but we'd like to be able to get
money to people you know we're very
lucky our country is doing so well we
can do this and we can do it easily but
we have to do it and I have to say Mitch
McConnell if you look at Mitch and Kevin
and the whole group and it's been it's
been incredible how they're reacting how
Congress is reacting how whether it's
the House or Senate how they're they're
moving and I'm talking about Democrats
and Republicans but we've had tremendous
leadership meetings and they want to see
it done right and they do want to go big
I think going big is important I don't
think we want to go up there every day
with a different idea a different
concept oh gee let's worry about the
airlines let's do this one you have a
big problem with the cruise ship
industry
it's a industry that was setting all
sorts of records two months ago that all
of a sudden
there's nobody on the ships okay so we
have to help these these are great in
these are going to be taking care of
people and passengers and and for years
to come and paying tremendous taxes
tremendous taxes for years to come so we
have to make sure that this is done yes
yes mr. president what you refer to just
a short while ago about politics I mean
your address to the nation you said we
have to put politics aside stop the
partisanship and unified together this
morning you criticize the Democratic
governor of Michigan yesterday was the
Democratic governor of New York you've
attacked Obama you've talked to the
attack Biden in fact every day except
one since that address
you've lashed out at a Democratic leader
are are you going to set the example
they only do that one I have to respond
I watched her on television she said
something that was false and therefore I
did do that and I will continue to do
that if they're not gonna play fair
because you know they have the media on
their side I don't I just have me and if
they're not gonna play fair all gonna do
that if they are gonna play fair there's
gonna be nobody there's gonna be nobody
better than Donald Trump in terms of
bipartisanship but if if they're going
to say things that are false like the
story that was written yesterday a lot
of people I don't know somebody I think
I know who but they taped the conference
call that I had with the governor's it
was a good call it was fine I assume
somebody's going to tape it they handed
it to various people one of it was the
New York Times and The New York Times
chose to write totally inaccurately
about it it was a disgraceful thing was
bad journalism but you know they do a
lot of bad journalism but we respond to
that and actually people get it people
get it no I want it to be bipartisan and
nobody's going to be better than me but
when they attack me or the people these
incredible people behind me I'm not
gonna let him get away with that I can't
do that okay how about one or two more
questions go ahead please
please clients with some was the next
natural step there's the next natural
step after that a national well you can
do a national lockdown hopefully we're
not gonna need that we think of
everything I mean we have every idea
that you mentioned we've thought of and
you know it's a very big step that's a
step that I mean in one sense would work
it's a very big step it's something we
talk about but we haven't decided to do
that please God
mr. president what would be the
determining factors for you to take that
action it would have to get to a level I
just don't think it's gonna be an action
that we're gonna take I don't think I'll
talk but Anthony all of the people
standing behind me would get together in
a room plus some additional x' and we
would make a decision but I don't think
that's a step that we're going to be
raging one more question you didn't have
one did you come on provide financial
assistance to Boeing and airplane
suppliers like GE we're looking at that
we're certainly looking at Boeing Boeing
got hit hard in many different ways
Boeing never had a problem for four
years they were they were an incredible
and it was unthinkable what happened
with respect to both unthinkable
probably I would consider it the
greatest company in the world prior to a
year ago now they get hit in 15
different ways and they have different
management
I've met the new people running Boeing I
think it's going to be outstanding but
you know we have to protect Bo and we
have to absolutely help help Boeing they
were doing a job they were getting it
was coming along well and then all of a
sudden this hits so obviously when the
airlines aren't doing well Boeing is not
going to be doing well so we'll be
helping Boeing you know mr. president we
really on what John was saying if you
call for people to leave politics out of
this Joe Biden said the World Health
Organization offered testing kits that
they had available to the United States
and to give it to us now we refused it
we didn't want to buy them PolitiFact
says the whn member made that offer can
you tell us well that's what I'm gonna
let I'm gonna let Tony answer that
question or some whoever's best at
answering that but
I do have to say when you talk about
politics I watch the debate not too
exciting but what they said about me and
we've done a great job when you talk
about not not being bipartisan what they
said about me and if you look at swine
flu the the whole thing and I guess it
was 2009 and what they did and the
mistakes they've made they were terrible
there were horrific mistakes 17,000
people died and I'll be honest they
shouldn't be criticizing because we've
done a fantastic job the only thing we
haven't done well is to get good press
we've done a fantastic job but it hasn't
been appreciated even the the closing
down of the borders which had never been
done and not only did we close in but we
closed them early the press doesn't like
writing about it so we've done a poor
job on press relationships and you know
I guess I don't know who to blame for
that I don't know maybe I can blame
maybe I can blame ourselves so that I
will blame ourselves but I think we've
done a great job I think we've done a
poor job in terms of press relationship
but let me have somebody answer your
question I tried to cover this in the
answer when I talked about quality of
kids and our quality analysis runs
through the FDA so all of these
platforms we have asked people to submit
and we've asked States to quality
control so I mean that anybody could
submit their tests to us we don't buy
tests that haven't been quality
controlled and they show us the data
either show us the data upfront or show
us the data after they've been running
them because quality testing for our
American people is paramount to us it
doesn't help to put out a test where 50%
or 47% are false positives imagine what
that would mean to the American people
imagine their level of concern now and
telling people that they're false
positive we take this same approach to
HIV imagine telling someone they were
positive to HIV and they weren't so that
is our bottom line the customer the
American people first
so any of these groups can submit their
testing kits through our regulatory
processes but without that and without a
plan we are not going to accept tests
that have not been studied by us good
answer - good answer
would you have something like that I'm
just gonna emphasize a little bit more
on that when I became involved in the
testing world I called as senior
officials at the WH o as I could find to
understand what the situation was and as
far as I can tell from sources that
should know no one ever offered a test
that we refused what I heard - this was
this is a research grade test right
research grade test that was never
submit was not approved not submitted to
the FDA that was supplied in tens of
thousands of quantities to a hundred
countries in the world okay so I think
there's a lot that people are saying
about this this is based on rumor and
myth nothing was offered that we refused
it was a research test that was not
approved and again there was a small
number that we have greatly surpassed in
a very short period of time so number
one nothing